here comes James two-point game harden  back out coming to the biggest shot of  the game Houston  timeout Utah  [Applause]  [Music]  when you're a player that gets traded to  another team in the middle of the season  you want to play well for your new fans  and this is the biggest shot of the  season here for Robert Covington and the  van der neat the basket 1.6 left to play  jingles trying to get it in having  trouble Bogdanovich  tough shot he went in then you talk jazz  hip one bozo  his second three-pointer of the game and  it never touched the other Donovan Wow  what a feather finish or the Houston  Rockets fan  throws this one up between two defenders  watch as he comes around the screen  he had James and TJ on him he throws it  up that's  basket of the game what a tough shot but  he drills it what Mikey wasn't covered  he was double-teamed on that stuff  Harden came over did a good job PJ was  all over the jazz bench explodes what a  fourth quarter as the Jazz out score  Houston